at the largest record store in the known
world Tower Records Columbus and babe in
a time when music couldn't be streamed
or downloaded Tower Records stood above
its competition with late night hours
knowledgeable employees and huge
inventories Tower Records was a go-to
for serious music fans I could talk
about me to them they could say have you
heard this they were like friends the
chain was founded in 1941 by Russ
Solomon who started selling used jukebox
records out of his father's Sacramento
drugstore Solomon who died this week at
the age of 92 is being remembered as a
visionary and a natural leader he had
really great ideas and he could put it
together and he could also encourage
other people to follow him that's why he
had the reputation and especially in the
early years of his business of being a
Pied Piper and the people just loved him
Russ Solomon and the rise of Tower
Records are the subjects of the 2015
documentary all things must pass I
called the number on the slide I said
you want to rent this place the guys had
loved him and I'm a BB tower expanded
from Sacramento to San Francisco in 1968
and at its peak maintained more than 270
stores each location was different with
Solomon giving individual store managers
control of what Records to stock and
encouraging his music-loving employees
to be themselves I got a job at Tower
Records because that's the only place I
could get a job with my haircut that is
the truth towers success put Solomon on
Forbes list of the 400 wealthiest
Americans but the dawn of digital music
downloads and a heavy corporate debt
load led to the end of the record chain
after selling a billion dollars worth of
Records in the 1990s tower declared
bankruptcy in 2004 and finally closed
its doors in America in 2006 but twelve
years on Tower Records is still
flourishing in Japan including a
nine-story flagship store in Tokyo
my favorite store ever
I was heartbroken when it closed and I
even went in I stole just to remind you
what record stores used to be real
document wean Queen was filed beneath
that cubase cute not a lot of it records
in queue but this was the best shape of
the ones that were left with FAO
Schwartz when I was a kid and power
records would have slept in Tower
world of wire up that place